civil rights advocates are asking
federal officials for records about
citizenship checks in Maine the law does
allow such actions near the border but
some are concerned about racial
profiling
here's correspondent Molly line US
Customs and Border Patrol agents in the
far north do far more than keep watch
over the country's frigid border with
Canada
at a bus station in Bangor Maine where
people often hop rides to bigger cities
agents recently asked boarding
passengers if they were US citizens the
American Civil Liberties Union of Maine
finds the practice troubling none of us
want to live in a society where we're
consistently being told we need to show
our papers though they declined our
request for an interview US Customs and
Border Patrol officials confirm they're
agents routinely engaged in operations
at the transportation hubs throughout
the state the law grants immigration
officers broad powers enabling them to
search for aliens on boats planes trains
buses and other vehicles without a
warrant within 100 miles of the border
that puts the whole of Maine within
reach and the entirety or near entirety
of ten other states - ACLU attorneys are
now seeking federal records we don't
know how widespread it is but we're
hoping to learn more it does seem like
there's been an increase in January
Border Patrol agents boarded a bus in
Fort Lauderdale Florida questioning
passengers people whipped out cell
phones and the video went viral one
woman who had overstayed a tourist visa
was removed last week a passenger on an
Amtrak train in Syracuse New York
captured video of agents asking those on
board about their citizenship at bus
stations in Maine reaction was mixed I
am a US citizen I'm proud of it I
appreciate the security as much as
anyone else but I think it's a violation
of our rights and our private
say I would rather be safe than sorry if
an agent approached me I'd be happy to
oblige whatever he asked me US Customs
and Border Protection provided a
statement explaining that enforcement
actions beyond the border are performed
as a means of preventing smuggling and
criminal organizations from exploiting
existing transportation hubs to travel
to the interior of the United States
Shannon our thanks to Molly line